All right, guys, this is a new chapter in this chapter.
I'm going to teach you guys the power of three and inverse
revenue gap model.
This model is extremely powerful.
And basically, if you use this model,
then you would not need anything else.
So essentially, first we need to understand what is power of three,
and then I'm going to teach you the model.
So power of three is basically an accumulation phase
where price consolidates, creates liquidity, then price
manipulates, and then it moves and distributes
towards the original direction.
Now we have accumulation, manipulation, and then
distribution.
This is power of three.
Accumulation, manipulation, distribution, A, M, D. Very simple.
And similarly, you have something like, oops, never mind,
accumulation, manipulation, and then distribution, right?
So what is the model that I use?
So what exactly is inverse for a value gap?
I've taught this before, but I'm going
to teach it again in this video.
So essentially, when you get a fairly gap,
so over here you can see that we got a market structure break
or break of structure.
And let's suppose that price creates a fairly gap,
a bullish fairly gap.
Now, this fairly gap will become inverse if price doesn't
respect it, and it closes below this bullish fairly gap.
So let me just make it green, because it
is a bullish fairly gap.
But notice how price came back into the fairly gap,
but it was not respected.
And you can see that the candle, the body,
closed below the fairly gap, so it was not respected.
Now, once the body closes, this fairly gap
becomes inverse for a fairly gap.
So essentially, what you can do is just simply
take your entry on the retest or on the close of the candle
below this level.
Right?
So the model that I use is basically, so now that you guys know
what exactly is an inverse fairly gap,
there are chapters on this, on my old course
and also on my YouTube.
So I'm not going to explain it in detail.
But here is the model.
So what I look for on the one minute time from,
and then there is another approach to it,
but this is like one minute trading strategy, right?
And you can basically trade it on NAS 100,
gold, and also your USD.
So I primarily trade NAS 100 with this,
because it has the highest wind rate.
So on the one minute time frame, I would try
to identify a accumulation phase,
then a manipulation phase, right?
And then afterwards, what I'm looking for,
so watch this carefully.
This is the most important part of this model.
So we have accumulation, and then we have manipulation.
Inside this manipulation leg, okay?
There should be only one fairly gap,
only one fairly gap, okay, on the one minute time frame.
So we have accumulation, then we have manipulation
inside the manipulation leg, right?
From this high to this low, we must have one fairly gap.
Now, let's suppose that this leg has,
okay, let me just guys, just give me a minute.
I'm just gonna disable this.
So it's connected to the LAN network.
Anyways, it should have one fairly gap,
but if it has multiple fairly gaps inside this leg, right?
What you want to do is you have to go a bit higher
on the time frame.
So you would go on the two minute time frame,
and then you would go on three minute time frame,
and then four, and then five.
The five minute is the highest that you can go.
But on the five minute, you must also have
a clear power of three, right?
You must have consolidation on the five minute time frame
as well.
Now, if there's like no power of three, right,
then there is no setup.
But let's say that you want to stick
on the one minute time frame, and I suggest
that you just stick to one minute time frame
because it's not cool to go to higher time frame
to identify a single fairly gaps.
So let's assume that while price was coming down
and manipulating, price created one single fairly gap.
And this is a bearish fairly gap.
Now, usually people would expect price to come
into this fairly gap and then go below.
But the model here is that once price
inverses this bearish fairly gap,
the single fairly gap that was present
inside this manipulation leg.
When price closes above that, you want to enter right away.
Okay, this is going to be your entry right away
when the candle closes above the fairly gap
and inverses it.
Your stop will go below here.
And this is the most important part.
You must target the most recent,
the most, the closest liquidity, right?
So this high is the closest level.
Now, let's suppose that your entry is triggered.
Now, here's a risk management for this strategy.
So, when the price reaches this,
the closest liquidity level, you are going break even, okay?
Straight away, you are going break even.
Now, when price hits one to one risk reward ratio,
you are taking 50% off your profit.
And of course, you are also break even.
And then you are letting the runners run
for however you want.
So for example, I usually go for one to 2.5
or one to three with the strat
and I target the high time frame, you know,
target and draw on liquidity.
Now, you can also use the standard deviation tool
that I've taught in my previous lectures
and you can target this level.
But the main premise, the main idea is that you go break
even once the closest liquidity level is taken, okay?
Now, here's the deal, okay?
Now, what price will do is sometimes,
just let me do this, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do.
Okay, what price will do is instead of closing above
the fair value gap, price will go up ahead
and take out the liquidity before giving you entry, right?
So the candle won't close but it will go way higher, right?
And then it will just take out the most recent liquidity.
Now, if that is the case, then the setup becomes invalid.
Completely invalid, okay?
I, my eyes are always on the most recent liquidity level.
That is the most recent high.
So this is the closest high, my apologies.
Now, the candle closes, price can even be here, okay?
Somewhere around here.
Now, you can enter right away, right?
And sometimes what can happen is price will go way far
up ahead.
So instead of entering here, you should be patient
and then you should be waiting for a retest entry.
Now, this is only applicable when the price has gone way far
above the inverse fair value gap.
And let's suppose that if you take your entry here,
your stop loss would be massive, right?
And it doesn't matter if you take your entry here or here,
you must go break even when the closest liquidity level
is taken out.
And that is basically the model.
Now, there are some few key things
that you must keep in mind.
Let me just take a sip of my tea and then I'll continue.
Thank you very much.
All right, now what I like to do most of the time
is basically pair it up with higher time
from key levels and SMT divergences.
Now, this is something that if you wanna like,
if you can implement this, then of course,
it's gonna increase the win rate, okay?
My goal is to teach you the most mechanical strategies
that you can use because I understand the situation
you guys are in.
You guys may have jobs and you don't have time,
enough time to analyze the markets every single day, right?
You know, you know, using discretion and all that stuff.
So I want to keep them as mechanical as possible.
If you really wanna like take this model to next level,
then use this technique.
So since we're trading on the one minute down from,
we will be marking out the 15 minute key levels, right?
So let's assume there was a significant low
somewhere around here that was taken out
and afterwards price gave us this AMD model, okay?
Now there could be a fair value gap,
50% of the fair value gap or an auto block, right?
It is always best to pair it this move with PD arrays.
Now, SMT divergence is basically,
let's suppose that on NAS100,
we created the lower low, lower high,
and then a lower low.
Essentially it is power of three,
but you can see we have lower low,
consolidation, and then another lower low.
Now, instead of on NAS100,
let's suppose that we get lower low, lower high, lower low,
but on S&P 500,
we fail to create the lower low, right?
Oh my God, this is messed.
Yeah, so we fail to create that.
Now, you wanna be trading the asset or the pair
that swept liquidity.
So you can see that we swept this liquidity, right?
On S&P, we failed to sweep the liquidity
or create another lower low,
but on NAS100, we created lower low, lower high,
lower low.
So this right here is your SMT with PD array in mind,
and I promise you, this is literally all you need.
Basically, all you need.
Now, here's another technique that you should implement,
if you can, that's gonna also increase your win rate.
So on the one minute timeframe, right,
we have single fair value gap.
We do not wanna have multiple fair value gaps.
Only one in this leg.
Now, okay, let's say is a price breaches
in versus this fair value gap.
Now, I will not enter right away.
What I would do is I would go to the three minute timeframe,
sorry, two minute timeframe,
and see if there's any other fair value gap
that price has not yet inversed, right?
So on the one minute timeframe,
your fair value gap could look like this,
but on the two minute timeframe,
your fair value gap could be a bit bigger,
and on three minutes timeframe, it could be even bigger.
Now, three minute is the highest
that I would go to implement this trick.
So I would wait for my highest fair value gap
to be inversed instead of the one minute.
Now, this is what it does,
it extra confirms that the price will go towards my direction.
Okay, this is very important.
So not actually important, but if you implement this,
it's gonna basically help you with your strike rate.
So SMT PD arrays and this technique
when combined together is just impossible
to basically have lower and red than a 75% percent, all right?
You're gonna have above 70 to 75% wind rate with this model.
Just stick to the pairs that I suggested
and assets that I suggested.
Don't trade anything else with this,
please don't do it for the sake of love, okay?
Don't do it.
And similarly, everything would apply
when you are looking for shots.
So basically, just do this and entry under retest.
We have SMT into the PD array
and you can see that we have accumulation, manipulation
and then we get the distribution phase.
And notice that also we have the closest liquidity level, right?
This is the main point of the strategy
is if it gets breached without entry, right?
So the candle just keeps going down and down and down
before closing below the fair value gap
then the setup becomes invalid.
However, if you have somewhere around here,
you can still enter but you would go break even right away.
After this level is taken, there's no comp,
you know, you should not be just doing things
when you're on just do what I say.
Take your entry on the retest
if price has gone way far below
or enter right away when price is somewhere around here.
Now, let's move on to the examples
and then we'll move on to the next chapter.
Now, one thing that I forgot to tell you about
is the time factor.
So when you should be trading this model,
now the best results are gonna come from 9.30, sorry,
till 11.30, right?
So if you can find however many setups in this window period,
your win rate is gonna be higher, okay?
You're gonna have volatility
but let's suppose that if there's news at 9.30, right?
You should wait for news to pass over
and trade after five to 10 minutes,
actually 10 minutes because it's gonna just
settle down the markets and then trade this model.
Let's suppose that there is a news at 10,
then you can do is wait till 10 and then trade after 10, 10 a.m.
That makes sense after 10 minutes.
So let me give you guys some examples.
All right guys, so here is example number one.
So we have accumulation right here
and then we have manipulation, right?
So let me just do this, accumulation,
manipulation and then we have the distribution
to the upside.
Now here's how you would have approached it, right?
So we get manipulation, right?
Now notice a lower low, lower high and then a lower low.
So our reference point is from this lower high
to this lower low.
Now notice what happens.
We have this fair value gap, right?
And we also have this closest liquidity level.
So if this level was taken out before our entry
then the setup would become invalid.
Now notice how price closed right above
the inverse fair value gap over here.
So this would have been your entry, okay?
And we would go break even with 50% profit
at one to one restore wall ratio.
Now you can see that this trade would have been closed
at break even unfortunately.
But you can see that price came back
and retested this IFVG and then we had another push
to take out these highs over here.
So I want to show this example
because not every trade is going to be perfect.
So this is how you would approach, right?
Accumulation, manipulation and then we have
this fair value gap that was inversed
and a beautiful entry here
with 50% profits taken here.
Let's move on to another example.
All right, so here is another example
on the same day.
You can see we have accumulation here
and then we have manipulation.
So essentially if you look for,
if you don't want to look for Power of Three
you can look for significant liquidity level streams
and then you can look for this model.
It's essentially the same thing.
Power of Three is going to come
in all different sizes and shapes and forms.
So it's not always mechanical.
You can't just identify Power of Three
in a mechanical way.
You have to see where the accumulation phase was
and the manipulation phase.
So accumulation phase, right?
Manipulation, then we get the distribution.
So how you would have approached this is basically,
you can also see that we swept this high over here.
Now, we have this low
and then we have this high over here, right?
Now notice this fair value gap.
Inside from this low to this high over here
there's only one fair value gap, okay?
So this is very crucial and you can see
that price inversed it just right here.
So this would be my entry right away.
Now you can see that my stop would go right above the high
and on one to one I would go,
actually I would go break even just around here
and then I would take 50% of the profits here
and as you can see price close to the set break
even once again.
But then you can see that price kept going down
and down and down for the rest of the day.
Price came back once again,
tried to stop you out of break even,
but then it kept going down.
So now there are different ways to approach this.
You can see that if you have taken your entry
on the retest over here, just around here,
this is the retest, stop somewhere around here
and you could have easily taken one to one over here.
Now, here is something that if you are really confident
about your draw on liquidity.
So for example, this is your draw on liquidity, right?
This is the closest liquidity level
that's when we go break even.
But if you are extremely confident
that okay price is going towards this high down frame,
you know, sorry, not the higher
but the significant liquidity level,
then this could be your target
and you can just avoid going break even.
You can simply just decrease your stop loss to some degree.
And then you can basically just go break even
when this level is taken, take like 50% off
and then keep it running.
But yeah, these are two examples
that show that this not every model,
sorry, not everything is perfect, right?
You're not going to get perfect trades every single time.
Now I'm going to show you guys the perfect examples
with the benefit of hindsight, right?
And you guys are going to understand it correctly.
All right guys, so here is the perfect example
and you can see we have the accumulation phase over here,
right?
And then we have the manipulation.
And while we manipulate it,
you can see that this leg created the Fair Valley gap,
the bullish Fair Valley gap.
But since most of the SMC traders are taught
to be taking a long position
after getting a break of structure,
you know, they get stopped out,
the price inverses this bullish Fair Valley gap.
So let me just color it green.
The candle closes here.
Now, this would be your entry,
your stop right out of the high.
This is the closest liquidity level.
So when this level is taken,
you would go break even right away, okay?
This you have to just go break even there.
There's just no ifs and buts, right?
But since I said before,
if your bias is extremely strong,
then you can just go break even later.
But you go break even right here, right?
And since we are trading on the one minute,
don't set, you know, stop loss orders
and take profit levels to be hit automatically.
You have to manage this trade manually.
So you can't, you have to manually close
when price reaches your stop loss level.
You have to manually go break even when price reaches
the exact break even point.
And then you have to take your profits
when price actually reaches this level, okay?
You just don't set up the levels
because what's gonna do is price will sometimes
stop you out at break even,
even when price is at due to spreads
and whatnot.
So it's just gonna really hurt you.
I'm not kidding.
It has happened to me before,
but I think this is the best approach is
keep watching the trade.
Since we are trading on the one minute,
you can be on the charts for 15 minutes, man.
Come on, bro.
You can't do that.
So break even here, 50% off at one to one.
And then the main target, the TP2,
would be somewhere around here, right?
And my last TP would be targeting the London lows.
And this would give me roughly around this much.
So this is like an extremely awesome model
that you can use guys.
It's basically a no brainer, okay?
I've explained everything.
SMTs to pair it up with,
so for example, if you look at it here, right?
We also swept the Asian high here, right?
So when you combine these different things
and take a trade with this model,
trust me, you're gonna thank me.
Now let's move on to the next example.
All right guys, so here is another example.
And you can see that in this price action,
you could have taken so many of these trades.
And some of them would have given you 50% profit at one to one.
And some of them would have been closed at break even.
But then there is, on the same day,
we have accumulation, right?
Somewhere around here.
And then we have the manipulation, right?
So basically, manipulation is liquidity sweep, right?
Over here.
And then notice that this leg created this bearish
Fair Valley gap.
So I'm just gonna name it, sorry, color it red.
Right?
So we close right above the Fair Valley gaps
that inverses it.
Now the closest liquidity level is this high over here.
So now you can see that if I take my long position
from this level and just put my stop here.
Now I would go break even when this level is taken, right?
And then I would take 50% off my profit at one to one.
And then my second tip would be somewhere around here, right?
Just around here, I would be break even.
And my third tipi, the final tipi that I would look to
is some form of high time frame level, right?
Because you can see that price just kept going up, bro.
That's insane, right?
So yeah, that would be,
or you can just take and close your entire position
on the second tipi, okay?
It doesn't really matter.
As long as you're making profits, it should not matter.
Let me give you guys one more example
and then we will end this chapter.
All right guys, so here's the final example.
And you can see we have a very clean borrowed three.
We have accumulation, then we have manipulation, right?
And the manipulation leg created this fair value gap,
the bullish fair value gap.
So let me just color it green
because it's a bullish fair value gap.
And now it's inversed.
This is the closest target, right?
So this is where we were gonna go break even.
So your entry would be here, stop somewhere around here, right?
Or maybe above the, actually above the high
and you would go break even here.
50% at one to one, right?
And your second tipi could basically be just this
because this is a significant high.
You can also see that this is a fair value gap.
This is an auto blog.
So this right here is a very good location
to take your profits, right?
One to one point five somewhere around that.
You would have got close every given if you held for longer
but you can surprise went further down below.
So this is a very good scalloping guys model
that you can use.
It is absolutely powerful.
Just pair it up with SMT, right?
And the PD arrays and you're gonna thank me, all right?
So thank you so much for watching.